Hallo, schönen guten Morgen, mein Name ist Dokuz. Ich bin zuständig erzielt für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stehen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden.
Na klar, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Barbara Schmidt.
Ja, Frau Schmidt, ich büchte Ihre Namen. Ihre Vorname wie BA, R, B, A, R, A.
Richtig.
Ihre Nachname wie Schule SCH, M, E, I, D, T.
Richtig, ganz klar.
Okay, freut mich Frau Schmidt, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
43 Jahre alt?
43 Jahre alt.
Okay, und wann sind Sie hier nachgeboren?
Am 20. Januar 1982.
82 Jahre alt.
Ganz genau.
Januar.
Und wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, ich bin 1,67 m groß.
Und ich wiege 61 kg.
Gut.
Frau Schmidt, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für mich werde ich ab?
Also ich habe seit ungefähr jetzt nur fast 2 Monaten zudem eine Schmerz in den Fingern.
Die werden immer stärker.
Finger, welche Finger?
Beide Hände, beide Finger, also die Finger von, also die ersten 3, die auch.
1, 3.
Aber im Prinzip geht das auch auf die anderen Finger über manchmal, auch auf den 4., auch auf den 5.
Meinen Sie, erste 3 Finger, beidseitige Schmerzen.
Genau, Fingergelenke.
Fingergelenke.
Okay.
Und haben Sie diese Schmerz morgen schlimmer als abends?
Ja, morgen sind sie schlimmer.
Ist Ihnen Gelenksteifigkeit bemerkt?
Ja, die letzten 3, 4 Tage habe ich auch Steifigkeit,
dass ich so ungefähr eine Stunde bis 90 Minuten brauche, bis die Finger wieder so auf sind.
Okay.
Können Sie beispielsweise morgens einfach die Glas mit schweren?
Ja, schwer ich.
Okay.
Wie ist das, wenn Sie die Schmerz, die Schmerz, die Galaphe, die Steine, die Weine, die Schmerzen,
die Sie in der Stärke schmerzen?
Sechs, sechs ungefähr.
Sechs.
Okay.
Wie ist das, wenn Sie die Schmerzen, die die Schmerzen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist das, wenn Sie die Stärke schmerzen?
Ja, von allem etwas, ein bisschen brennend, ein bisschen dumpf, ein bisschen stetschend, ein bisschen pikstend.
Ein allem etwas.
Mhm.
Brennende Stärke.
Okay.
Und, nehmt es wieder, geht es netwas?
Ja, ich nehme jetzt seit ungefähr 2 Wochen Musik über Profäne einnehmen, ja.
Ich möchte das jetzt schon besser.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie ein?
400 Milligramm.
400.
Ja.
Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, so 2, 2 Mal ungefähr am Tag.
2 Mal und hüft.
Ein bisschen, ja, also der Schmerz ist nicht ganz weg, aber es wird erträglicher.
Mhm.
Sie haben Schmerzen.
Haben Sie auch Schwillungen oder Überwärmung, Rötungen am Gelenk bemerkt?
Also ich habe bemerkt, dass mein Ehring schwieriger rein und raus geht.
Ja, Schwillungen meint man.
Ein bisschen, ja, ich denke schon.
Mhm.
Schwillungen.
Aber keine Rötungen, keine Überwärmung, nur Schwillungen.
Genau, ja.
Mhm.
Keine Rötungen.
Eine Überwärmung.
Hab es Fiber?
Nein.
Mhm.
Und Frau Schmidt, haben in Ihren Familien, in den 5 Werden, Familien mitgelegt, meine Mutter, Vater, Geschwister?
Nicht bekannt.
Eine Familie.
Mhm.
Keine.
Gut.
Frau Schmidt.
Haben Sie eine Idee?
Oder was machen Sie beruflich?
Wir Lehrerinnen, Gutschulle Lehrerinnen.
Gutschulle Lehrerinnen.
Sie tragen nicht so Schwierigkeite, oder?
Nein, ich nicht.
Gutschulle Lehrer.
Haben Sie sich das bei der Arbeit?
Ich mache meinen Job gerne.
Ich treffe keine.
Sie haben keine Fieber.
Nur Handelfinger.
Gibt es viele Kinie oder Schulter, die andere Gelenk, Merzen?
Das bin ich bewusst. Nein.
Haben Sie Atem noch?
Nein.
Keine Fieber?
Nachschweiß oder Schütterfrost?
Nein, auch nicht.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ganz gut eigentlich.
Ich bin nur ein wenig erschöpft in den letzten 1-2 Wochen, fühle ich mich ein bisschen kraftlos.
Kraftlos, müde.
Ja.
Müde, verstehe.
Und, ja, ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Ja, frage ich mich, haben Sie früher nicht erwischt?
Nein, noch nie.
Und, ja, schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Keine Schlafsprobleme?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht Wasser lassen?
Selten, ganz selten, wenn ich viel trinke.
Selten.
Ist Ihnen Bein, ist Ihnen Ihren Unterschenkel oder Schwillungen aufgefallen?
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Liegen Sie flach?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ja, können Sie flach liegen?
Ja.
Gut, ist keine Probleme mit.
Ist Ihnen in der letzten Zeit Gewissverlust aufgefallen?
Gewissverlust?
Ja.
Ich habe circa 2 kg verloren, aber...
Ihr wart ihr seit Raum?
Ja, in den letzten 2 Monaten ungefähr.
Ungewöhnlich, meine Sie?
Ich wiege ich und sehr wenig, also für meine Größe.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das jetzt so...
Das ist normal.
Ich weiß nicht.
Okay.
Sie haben seit 2 Monaten so nehmende Finger schmerzen.
Aber Sie haben keine Fieber, Nordschwillungen, keine Überwärmung
und Bewegung einschränkungen.
Sie haben Bewegung einschränkungen.
Und diese schmerzen keine Strahlen.
Sie haben keine Stechende schmerzen.
Ich helfe das für Sie.
Und in der Familie keine ähnliche Probleme.
Sie haben ungewöhnliches Weihkühle abgenommen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, diese kranken Geschichte?
Ja, Sie haben alles genannt.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich kann nicht.
Gut, und mussten Sie im Krankenhaus übernachten?
Oder stationäre?
Wurden Sie schon einmal stationäre behandelt?
Ja, aber ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Geburten?
Wie wurde Sie geburten? Normaler oder...?
Normaler.
Wie alt ist Ihr Kind?
10 und 13.
10 und 13, das ist normal.
Sie haben keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Nicht das Schmerzen.
Gut, und wo ist Ihr schon einmal operiert?
Nein, ich nicht.
Super.
Was haben Sie mit dem Bein geblieben?
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin Profil.
Ja, ich habe auch gesagt, ich bin Profil.
Sie sind allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein.
Unverträglichkeiten?
Vertreten Sie alles mit dem Schmerzen?
Ja, ich finde schon.
Noch einmal bitte.
Ich vertrage alles.
Nein, super.
Super.
Frau Schmidt, ragen Sie?
Nein.
Noch nicht? Ja, früher auch.
Ich denke, ich hauche nicht.
Super, super.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten.
Bei Feiern, Kurztage, dann trinke ich mal Wein.
Anlässlich trinken Sie nur gelegentlich.
Ich höre nicht.
Noch einmal bitte.
Wie oft trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten. Nur bei Feiern oder Geburtstagen.
Gut.
Und, lieben Ihre Eltern noch Fraschen?
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Mein Vater ist verstorben.
Es tut mir sehr leid zu hören.
Woran verstorben, ist Ihr Vater?
Sie hat eine Schilddrüßenerkrankung.
Ich habe ein Motor.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Ich glaube, Sie nimmt Tabletten dafür.
Was?
Sie nimmt Tabletten dafür.
Gut. Es geht gut gerade?
Ja, sie fühlt sich gut.
Haben Sie eine Schilddrüßenerkrankung?
Ja, ich habe eine Schilddrüßenerkrankung.
Haben Sie eine Schwesterfrasche?
Nein, ich bin ein solcher Kind.
Sie sind Grundschülerin.
Sie sind zufrieden mit der Arbeit.
Wie ist Ihre Familie?
Ich bin verheiratet, habe zwei Kinder.
Ja, Sie haben es schon gesagt.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, toll, toll. Alles gesund.
Wie ist Ihre Liste?
Normalerweise.
Wie war Ihre Liste?
Das war ungefähr vier Monate, Anfang des Jahres.
Okay, war es auch.
Wie war es?
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Anfang des Jahres.
Okay, war alles in Ordnung?
Sie sagt ja.
Wie verhütten Sie?
Ich habe eine Spirale.
Spirale.
Okay.
Frausch mit...
Sind Sie in nächstes Jahr in Ostland gereist?
Nein, aber nicht an Ostland.
Im Westen waren wir in Holland in der Niederlande.
Finalement?
Über Ostertage.
series attention.
Du se wurdest stayed in schönem Urlaub gehabt.
Gut.
Ich bin schon fertig.
Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Frau Schmidt, ich denke für Sie eine Gelenkentsündung,
aber ich habe nur Verdacht gerade.
Deswegen muss ich ein paar Untersuchungen bei Ihnen durchführen,
Labor-Untersuchungen und körperliche Untersuchungen.
Danach sage ich,
richtige Diagnose für Sie sagen.
Muss ich heute hier bleiben oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Nein, ein paar Stunden noch.
Können Sie ein paar Stunden bei uns bleiben.
Danach können Sie nach Hause gehen.
Okay, verstanden.
Normatöris, artritis, oder?
Ich habe das in der Gelenk.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Hatten Sie früher Vergebot?
Nein.
Hatten Sie Schmerktar links, eltern auf den Gesicht?
Noch mal.
Schmerktar links, alt, ausschlag im Gesicht.
Schmetter links, lukus, nein.
Verlindet die Schmerzen mit Bewegen?
Die Schmerzen werden morgens, sind die sehr stark und sehr steig,
meine Finger, aber die Schmerzen werden im Laubetag besser,
auch die Beweglichkeit wird besser, aber die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Alles klar.
Entschuldigung, bei Katwürze,
Ihre Schmerzen starken oder?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Das habe ich nicht überprüft.
Okay, danke.
Stuhlgang, Wasserlasschen ist okay, keine Probleme.
Keine Bauchschmerzen, keine anderen Schmerzen.
Langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, das war so ungefähr zwei Monate nach dem Angefangen.
Das wird jetzt immer mehr.
Ich muss deutlich mehr Ibuprofen nehmen,
damit ich überhaupt meinen Alltag bewältigen kann.
Wenn ich morgens die Kinder fertig mache,
oder Frühstück vorbereite,
ist es schon sehr anstrengend und sehr schmerzhaft für mich.
Nur Differenziativismus habe ich gefragt.
Ich habe keine Zwecken gehabt.
Können Sie ein Glasdecken einfach öffnen?
Morgen ist es schwierig, im Laufe des Tages geht das.
Okay, in der Nacht auch die Kinder,
die sich auf die Kinder verabschieden,
haben Schmerzen, Zwiebel oder...
Ja, morgens, wenn ich das Pausenbrot für die Kinder vorbereite,
oder das Frühstück habe ich schon mal in der Nacht,
dann habe ich das
oder das Frühstück habe ich schon manchmal beschwerden.
Das heißt manchmal eigentlich fast immer.
Wie lange dauern Ihre Morgensteifigkeit?
30 Minuten?
Ich habe schon eine Stunde bis eineinhalb Stunden.
Ich habe das schon verantwortet.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Sehstürungen bemerkt?
Nein, das ist zwar langfristig.
Ich habe keine Begründung.
Herr Kollege, ich habe eine kleine Frage.
Können Sie uns ein Glasdecken geben?
Ja.
Bitte, danke.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag,
schönen guten Morgen Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte,
es geht um Frau Barbara Schmidt.
Sie ist 40 Jahre alt, 1,67 m groß.
Frau Schmidt startete sich bei uns vor seit zwei Monaten,
bestehende Zunehmenden.
Insbesondere, ich merke,
insbesondere Handelfinger, Handelfinger,
die des weiteren Klages über die Steifigkeitfinger
und Schüwellung.
Die Dichmersen-Intensität liegt bei 6,10 auf der Numerischeskala.
Die Dichmersen wurden 10,
die Dichmersen-Strahlen nicht,
die Schmerzen sind ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Schmerzen sind ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Fragen nach FIBA, die Familienanamnese,
die Schmerzen sind ohne Ausstrahlung.
Wir haben die Schmerzen, die die Schmerzen sind,
die die Schmerzen sind, die die Schmerzen sind,
dass sie keine Erkrankungen für Operationen haben,
und sie nehmen bei Bedarf Ibuprofen ein Mal.
Dagegen dieser Schmerzen nehmen sie auch Ibuprofen,
400mg Warmert,
die weniger Hilfe gebracht haben.
Sie haben keine Allergie und Vertragsschuldigkeiten.
Sie sind nicht racher und trinken sehr sartem Wein.
Die Familienanamnese Erga, ihre Mutter,
leider an Hashimoto Truditis.
Ihr Vater sei an Myokartinfarktus verstorben.
Sie sei Grundschule, sie sei Lehrer bei einer Grundschule.
Sie sind zufrieden bei der Arbeit. Sie sind ein gesundes Kind.
Die reiseanamnese, die genecolokrische Anamnese und reiseanamnese, sind unauffällig.
Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf,
Rumatitis, Arthritis hin.
Die differenzialen Diagnostiken kommen aber, es ist keine Fieber.
Sie sind in der Ergänzung, die die Anamnese verwendet haben.
S violating Diagnose.
3.000 Rohprozenten, keine Morgensteiligkeit.
Morgensteiligkeit?
Ja, mehr als auch Nachts wie Schmerzen und Kribbeln.
Und Taubheitsgefühle, sie hat keine Taubheitsgefühle.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, sehr.
Sie hat keine Taubheitsgefühle.
Mhm.
Ich denke, Ihre Verdachtdiagnose ist richtig,
mit Rheumatolida, Drittes.
Zumal Ihre Mutter auch eine Hashimoto hat.
Also eine Beinlagung für Autoimmunerkrankungen gibt.
Was machen Sie mit dieser Patientin?
Was haben Sie vor, welche Diagnostischen Mittel werden Sie einsetzen?
Ja, zuerst muss ich ausführliche körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Diese Gelenkveränderungen, Gelenkschmerzen,
insbesondere Handgelenk und Finger, auch die Ellenborgen.
Alle Gelenk muss ich untersuchen.
Die Staffigkeitsuntersuchung,
die Schwellungen, Überwärmungen,
die ich möchte, die septische Artritis ausschließen,
aber sie hat keine Fieber.
Dann natürlich auskulturelle ich Lungen,
weil die Romatitis, Artitis, Mag, Lungen.
Lungen, ich höre Lungen, auskulturelle Lungen.
Und Herz.
Danach werde ich Labor und Untersuchung durchführen,
insbesondere Blutbild-Entzündungsparametrasie,
RP, BSG und Rolno-Marker.
Und SCP.
Antis SCP.
Antis SCP, Antiköp.
Und diese, wenn ich röntge,
dann kann ich die Handgelenk in die Sreihebenen veranlasen.
Mhm.
Und dann ...
Ich habe nicht viel von den CT-Aberbrauchen gemacht.
Mhm.
Und würden Sie ja schon etwas geben an Medikamenten,
wenn der Verdacht sich bestätigt?
Wenn wir verdacht bestätigt, nachdem diese Blutsurkane natürlich
elektro- und levane-Renate ausseht,
dann werde ich Kleinigkeit Cortison-Tableten.
Schmerz-Tablet, kleine Menge,
vielleicht fünf Milligramm oder weniger.
Zum Wenig.
Und Cortison-Tableten, Chlorokin-Tableten
und Schmerz-Tableten
und GG-Bene-Unfalls ...
Chlorokin werden Sie geben.
Anti-Immun-Tablet.
Chlorokin.
Macht man das noch? Ich glaube, man macht das nicht mehr.
Macht man das ja nicht?
Vielleicht gibt es auch Probleme, deswegen, oder?
Chlorokin gibt man bei Rheumatriatris, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Ah, vielleicht.
Es gibt etwas anderes, Cortison-Tableten.
Das ist die andere Medikamente.
Das ist die Methodexamplein.
Danke.
Was geben Sie zuerst? Cortison oder MTX?
Beides, Susanne.
Was hilft schneller?
Cortison natürlich.
Vielleicht erst mal Cortison ansetzen.
Und dann, wenn sich die Pädatriago so bestätigt,
dann MTX gleich am nächsten Tag probieren.
Ja.
Sofort kann man nicht mit MTX schreiben.
Normalerweise muss man nicht ein Aufklärungsgespräch führen.
Nein, nach dem diese Ergebnisse kann man mit Rheumatriaks.
Oder Azitiprin, Cilazoprin, oder?
Ja, kann man sicherlich auch diesen D-Mars,
also den DS-ARMS, heißen die, die kann man dann ansetzen.
Erste Wahl ist hier auch MTX.
Ja, auch kann man Vitamin D und Casium-Tableten schreiben.
Ja, das ist eine supportive Therapie.
Keine kausale Therapie.
Ja, natürlich.
Weil wir werden Cortison einsetzen, oder?
Ja, Cortison, sollte man auch ausschleichen irgendwann.
Also nicht auf Dauer-Cortison geben, wenn es geht nur.
In der Akutphase, um die Patienten zu entlasten mit ihren Schmerzen.
Aber man sollte irgendwann auf MTX zum Beispiel,
wenn es gut vertragen wird, umswitschen.
Sei es Urschalen, sei es Oralen.
Ja, und auch die Proflaxie ist Therapievollsäure.
Genau.
Die Dämon-Chance.
Ganz genau.
Es ist wichtig.
Ja.
Das ist wichtig, ganz genau.
Imp-Status wurde nicht erfragt.
Den Impfstatus haben Sie nicht erfragt.
Das wäre wichtig gewesen.
Ja.
Da mussten wir noch mal nachfragen.
Durchfalle brechen, Gastrointestinelle beschwerden.
Haben Sie nicht nachgefragt?
Mhm.
Das sollen Sie noch mal nachfragen.
Brennen beim Wasserlassen oder so.
Ja, ich habe...
Das müssen Sie noch mal nachfragen.
Das wäre wichtig gewesen.
Das wäre wichtig.
Wegen der urinale Infektion macht auch die Schmerzen.
Genau.
Sie Blut bemerkt haben, wenn Sie urinieren.
Ja, sie machen vielleicht...
Ja, das ist genau.
Die Fieber, keine Fieber, die sind wirklich auf dem Boden.
Aber sonst war die Diagnose richtig.
Ich denke, es ist kein Kapalton und Syndrom.
Es ist auch keine Arthrose.
Arthrose macht andere Beschwerden.
Aber...
Rheumatöidatrisis ist, glaube ich, die zutreffende Diagnose.
Mhm.
Was sollte man noch machen bei Rheumatöidatrose?
So für die Zukunft außer MTX, Autokortison?
Das kann man noch machen.
Hm.
Erläutig.
Nachdem diese Apothefas bewogen, können wir Physiotherapie empfehlen.
Genau.
Man sollte den Patienten oder die Patientin an einen Rheumatologin
oder Rheumatologin verweisen.
Mhm.
Damit es weiter scharf als betreut werden kann.
Ja, genau.
Mhm.
Die Patientin hat, ist 43 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Rheumatöidatrisis ist die alte Einmischen-Hoch, oder?
Das ist die Welt.
Es gibt nichts, was nicht gibt.
Es kann alles geben.
Der eine bekommt Herzinfarkt, der andere mit 100 Jahren.
Mhm.
Haben Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Äh, wer ist das?
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich weiß nicht.